power
energy
synchronization
fluidity
these are all words that describe taiko
drumming as we see and hear it today
known as the heartbeat of japan the art
form balances music dance and athletics
into a dynamic demonstration of japanese
culture the word taiko means drum in
japanese
this is kumidaiko an ensemble-based form
of taiko and if you've ever seen a taiko
performance before this might be what
you recognize there are two things that
may surprise you about this art form one
that it was developed as recently as
1951 and two that it may not exist
without the influence of jazz
[Music]
so i'm a drummer and my background is in
jazz and in gospel but i've never played
taiko before so in this video linda and
i are going to learn about kumidaiko and
i'm going to get a taiko lesson later on
and see how it compares to jazz drum
nice to meet
you we're gonna just start with some
very very basic things like just
breathing this is the way we start a
rehearsal or a class is three different
breaths big breaths and the final thing
is there's a key eye that's the vocal
part of taiko
just an expression of the spirit so
sometimes it's you know it's written
it's part of the music everyone who
learns the song learns the key eye to go
with it um but a lot of times it's just
how you feel in the moment yeah
rhythmic instruments have existed in
japan for around 2000 years drums
brought in from china were adapted into
a uniquely japanese style a style that
facilitated the practice of shinto an
indigenous japanese religion which
worships ancestors and nature spirits
through this spiritual art form taiko
became an intimate part of many village
activities taiga would later become a
big part of matsuri or religious
festivals every town in ancient japan
would hold their own festivals that
began to incorporate taiko drumming and
dancing due to their deep resonant
sounds taiko were also used by the
military and townsfolk as a way to
deliver messages or signals across large
distances for hundreds of years tycho
existed in these two ways
as an essential part of dancing at
religious festivals and a communication
device in 1951 a jazz drummer named
daihachi oguchi was asked to play an old
sheet of taiko music discovered in an
attic when he was finally able to
interpret the old japanese notation he
discovered that the music was extremely
simple because it was written to be
played in unison he began toying with
new more complex ideas and later
realized that different types of taiko
played by a group of people could be
used to effectively emulate a western
drum set
these mid-sized drums here we call the
chudaiko chew daiko
and they generally hold the melody okay
and this is just very general over here
daiko chudaiko okay this is the shime
means to tighten and so you can tighten
with bolts or rope that's the highest
pitched sound and that's usually your
time keeper your your beat keeper your g
keeper i like that the shime is very
similar to the snare drum absolutely
exactly totally so this is the big bass
this is our largest drum which is the oh
daiko oh daiko
this is tiffany tamaribuchi not only was
she the first female foreigner to win an
odyco competition in japan
she also created the first all-women
taiko ensemble jodico
i want to know how did you choose to
play the odaiko was it that power that
was a part of it or were you just drawn
to it i was drawn to
the physicality and the power in it and
the overall style of it the way it
really involves your whole body the way
it
involves a lot of spirit and a lot of
presence and a lot of power i had a
motivation to learn the style and as i
started to do it i actually learned i
was pretty good at it and then we add
the phrases right so the phrases are
simple
so um
don hit in the center
[Music]
a hit on the wood
and then how you play it is how you say
it so yes i'll say
[Music]
go
[Music]
various kumi daiko groups were
established in the 1950s and 60s some of
these groups such as kodo still exist
and perform around the world today taiko
existed prior to 1951 but the art form
was completely reinvented
since then kumidaiko has spread to all
corners of the world it became a way for
japanese americans to reclaim their
japanese heritage inspired by the civil
rights movement in the 1960s
to connect with that part of culture in
that part of history is important to me
and so to be able to as a japanese
american
connect with
that part of my heritage in japan and to
be accepted as a woman and as an
american and as
a taiko player
was also important to me and my sense of
identity
you know these drums are huge and they
take so much physical power and that's
something that you know regardless of
traditions that's something that's
really identified as male and when you
when you flip that and have these
gorgeous
amazing women playing so powerfully but
playing with their own kind of energy
and experience it's it's sort of
revolutionary speed
so
[Music]
now now after you hit do this hit and
just make sure there you go there you go
see that hit
now on the way out
float
float
float float float float float float all
the way back so pretty okay until you're
ready to hit again hit it again
and then float and then
like your laser cutting across the sky
float all the way all the way back then
you look much bigger
like so yeah
look at that okay one more
okay okay yeah you got to be strong
don't
don't
don't huh
huh
[Music]
okay okay so
kai and dong is just boom and cat yeah
to me right boom in the center cat cat
cat on the edge so same idea yep boom
boom cat ba boom boom boom okay
same thing yeah can we um can we play
together yeah i'd love to can you play a
rhythm yeah
yeah yeah
okay so i'll say all right my way
yes but we'll figure it out how to say
it the title way okay and this is how it
goes it goes like this one
two three like this
boom boom okay taiko has brought
together communities of all ages and
genders to play and dance to the
heartbeat of japan
[Music]
thanks so much for watching our episode
on taiko drumming if you want more on
taiko be sure to check out this video on
if cds could dance tiffany shares with
us how taco drumming has impacted her
life and how it keeps her community in
sacramento strong
and here are your submissions from our
last video where we asked you what your
favorite brandy vocal moment is brandy's
catalog is without a doubt iconic but i
have to say my favorite song for
brandy's offered latest album b7 uh and
it's called borderline the vocal
harmonies in that song is absolutely
ridiculous i still lose words when i
think of the song